dass sie nicht
für team süd geht es weiter in bechtheim
in rheinhessen
diese region ist berühmt für ihren wein
bis der in der flasche ist gibt es auf
den weingütern viel zu tun
auch der junge winzer johannes keil
könnte hilfe in den weinbergen
gebrauchen jetzt mitten in der saison
arbeitet aber genug und wir haben sogar
aufgaben für euch auf einem weingut
helft ihr bei der traubenernte achtet
auf die rebsorten die ihr kennenlernt es
gibt nicht nur eine beinahe es gibt
viele rebsorten wir haben einige davon
im anbau die möchte euch heute zeigen
dass ich mal seht wie in deutschland
frei gemacht wird
ich habe mir jeden von euch rebschere
mitgebracht das schwierigste ist
eigentlich nicht so wie trauben zu essen
das ist das ernten der trauben nennt man
weinlese wichtig ist dass wirklich nur
reife und frische beeren in den eimer
kommen super aber ich habe schon ein
bisschen bauchweh weil ich habe sehr
viele gegessen
welche ressort ist dass das ist die
muskateller muskateller rewe ist eine
der ältesten kultur eben die es gibt und
zeichnet sich durch den schönen würzigen
muskat geschmack riesling ist
deutschlands wichtigste rebsorte gibt
ganz ganz hervorragende weine riesling
ist nicht so schön wie muskateller und
die müssen ein bisschen am stock bleiben
zurück im weingut die bären in diesen
bottichen müssen gestampft werden
und draußen auf dem hof wartet schon die
dritte rebsorte
das ist so knobloch und jetzt probiert
man eine beere
die bären haben ein sehr schönes
heftiges aroma das nach grüne paprika
schmeckt sondern meistens sehr rätsel
die aus frankreich zu uns gekommen ist
und den letzten jahren hier stark
verbreitung von drei rebsorten heute
kennen gelernt und ihr sollt aus diesen
fünf decks orten diese drei heraus
finden und zuordnen zählt zu den staaten
die dieses schöne muskat aroma haben
diese mehr säure mehr raus als der
muskateller ich kann das leicht erkennen
die sonst haben wir ein sehr schönes
patrick aroma das nach grüne paprika
schmeckt hab keinen kopf nicht rein
jetzt zeigt sich wie gut die drei
aufgepasst haben
was ganz einfach war das ist auch
richtig süßes muskat aroma diese bären
hier sind deutlich saurer als alle
anderen riesling und sauvignon blanc
haben die drei nicht erkannt für euch
gibt es heute leider kein ticket
es steht weiterhin 3 zu 3 diese aufgabe
hat das team leider nicht geschafft
muss sich
was sie nicht brauchen